why don't we go next to oh I don't know
how about
um how about Ryan from Dallas Texas Ryan
welcome to the program what's on your
mind today
hello David can you hear me yes I can
uh thank you for taking me um so I was
just wondering like you know you have a
lot of these extreme ideologies being
pushed by the right to stir up the group
of people on the left who don't follow
the news as much
um so they don't know the specific
details on certain topics for instance
like the
um like the Dylan Mulvaney uh saying
they were saying that uh he came out or
she came out you know the saying that
she was a spokesperson for temp for
tampons or something like that and it
was just like that wasn't even what
happened apparently she had said that
she kept one on her sometimes or
whatever you know for a friend or
whoever may need it or whatever and so I
just sometimes it's difficult because I
have friends who you know are on the
left but they they don't actually follow
the news like I had a friend who
mentioned that oh Kamala Harris hasn't
been you know in the public since she
came into office and so uh like she
hasn't been seen in public at all
yes and uh even though you can follow
her on YouTube uh weekly and so I just I
don't know I just kind of wanted to hear
your thoughts on that yeah it's a pro I
have a lot of conversations with people
where they uh they they'll say things
like listen you know I grew up in a
democratic family but like this woke
stuff it's really got to end and I'll go
oh okay like what do you mean they go no
it's just you know it's crazy what's
happening with with uh with antifa and
it's just crazy it's like everything's
so woke you can't do anything anymore I
go oh like what what can't you do they
go no it's just it's like it's just the
it's the environment it's the feeling of
like you just can't everything you say
you're gonna get in trouble for nobody
oh like what is it you're trying to say
that you think you'll get in trouble for
well no it's not me but like you know
and you'll spend 10 minutes like this
and it goes nowhere it goes nowhere and
it's still like yes someone who's voting
for Biden or whatever but it is kind of
disappointing
yes and and I'm actually kind of worried
um because although um I think that
Bonnie has done um I would say a a
decent job um as president I think that
um him being 80 um and running for
president again I think he's only doing
it just so that he can defeat Trump
because maybe you know the Democratic
party are afraid of trump winning but I
don't think that um Biden running at
this eight at his age is actually going
to be uh good for the Democratic party
as far as interest no I don't think it's
gonna it's it's not inspiring it doesn't
generate uh it doesn't generate interest
in the way that uh you're you're sort of
talking about I I agree with you
completely and you know there are people
who write to me and go David I don't
know that Biden can defeat Trump
if you look at polling if Biden can't I
don't know that anyone else in
particular can either I mean Trump has a
significant level of support in this
country as shocking as that may be I
don't know who can beat Trump
yes and I have one last quick question
um I know previously you had mentioned
that you weren't a Democrat but I saw in
your video the other day you mentioned
you were a progressive Social Democrat
so I was just trying to confirm which
which it was so Social Democrat the D is
lower case it's not a party affiliation
so I'm not a capital D Democrat I'm not
a member of the democratic party I don't
um I'm not a I'm an independent voter
from a party affiliation standpoint
Progressive social democracy is an
ideology not a party so the D is lower
case you know what I'm saying yes yes
yes I think that is basically the the
clearest explanation
that'll help me for my next conversation
with my friends so thank you all right
Ryan thanks for the call
all right there goes Ryan let's go um I
mean against my better judgment let's go
to Donald from Palm Beach Florida I'm a
little worried about this
uh Donald from Palm Beach Florida you're
on the air
okay Donald from Palm Beach Florida uh
clearly it was a joke they bailed very
very funny joke let's go next to
um actually let's try once more Donald
from Palm Beach did you are you actually
trying to get on what's going on you're
not getting afraid now whatever joke you
were gonna do
yeah they are all right uh well
they're gone
how about uh let's go to Louis from New
Brunswick Louis from New Brunswick
welcome to the program
thank you Dave it's so good to be on
your program pleasure oh I just want to
jump in on something that the the last
guy was saying Ryan sure I was I I
noticed as well that people were
throwing around the word woke quite a
bit uh at work and just just around and
I realized that it meant vastly
different things to different people so
I started asking people can you just
help me understand what that word means
right and I was being a little facetious
and like I noticed like the older
generation talked about like being hyper
uh hypersensitive take you know taking
offense and it was like you know
pejorative like oh I don't like walk
like it's going woke all over the place
I asked young people
uh especially people especially like um
people who might identify as being a
minority
um and they were like no it actually has
a lot to do with just understanding the
historical
context of of you know of historical
wrongs and uh so I think there's a huge
problem I think that the right really
weaponized the words so it's almost uh
you know it's like a bad word in a sense
I'd go further I mean so first of all
Louis I have a YouTube clip called
something along the lines of they don't
even know what woke means where I talk
about a lot of this stuff in detail I
would go further than to say that
they've weaponized the word woke the
right has actually perverted the word
woke because really what woke originally
meant when the left used it seriously
now it's pretty facetiously used but
when the left use the word woke
what was meant was I'm aware of problems
in society some of which are more
structural than about the individual and
I would like to find solutions to those
problems like that that's that was
really the meaning of woke when it was a
sincere term and it's been weaponized
and perverted from the right by the
right I don't really know anyone
seriously using it like sometimes I'll
joke around like friends will say to me
someone will recommend the TV show for
example or a movie and then someone else
in the conversation will describe the
plot and someone will say sort of
tongue-in-cheek ooh sounds like it might
be a little too woke for me and it's a
joke you know everybody the the term has
now become one that I don't know of
people on the left actually using in a
serious way
interesting yeah because the right
definitely uses it in a serious way I
got another question for you
um a couple months ago you had one of my
favorite authors Jefferson Morley on the
program wondering if you'd be able to
bring them back anytime soon well you
know we don't tend to have authors on
more than like once a year but I'm glad
to have them on again in the future for
sure
he does a great subsequent he talks you
know primarily about investigating
um the JFK assassination he's really up
to date on on um on disclosure coming
from the the government okay so I got a
question today uh NASA actually held a
public forum on their investigations of
UAP so like I guess that's like the
modern word for UFOs yeah
so here's my question to you uh
Jefferson Morley would pause and I think
a lot of people agree that there's still
a lot of uh disclosure that hasn't
happened in terms of the JFK
assassination case
now there's a lot of stuff going on in
the uh in like mainstream media like
from NASA today about UFO disclosure so
here's my question do you feel like this
is uh is this like a an endemic issue in
our in our modern society where there's
a lot of information that's being
withheld from the public
I don't know that it's a particularly
modern issue there's a long history of
the classification of documents there
are entire books written about whether
there is over classification I did an
interview about it I don't believe it's
specific or conspiratorial to uaps and
Kennedy is what I would say but there
are other people who have far more to
say about that issue than I do
so um David during the lockdown period
my wife and I really enjoyed watching
your show on YouTube live it was it was
almost therapeutic so I just want to say
thank you you're doing a great job
thanks for checking my call Louie thank
you so much very much appreciate that
that will do it for live calls today
we'll do more calls don't worry we'll do
it again we'll take a quick break and be
back with much more on the Friday show
right after this